[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of my dear friend the hilarious
Jay Larson who's full free stand-up
special sounds like Bruce is available
on YouTube now check that out he's so
funny he's hilarious and he's wonderful
you're about to hear he's just a
wonderful guy an inspiring guy and a
very interesting guy I'm also on tour
thank you to everybody I'm also on tour
thank you to everybody that came out in
Minneapolis what an incredible weekend
and we have lots and lots more tour
dates coming up go to petehomes.com hope
to see you I think there's New York
Connecticut there's all sorts of stuff
Cleveland was just added just go to
pdoms.com see if I'm coming to a town
near you hope that I am and hope that
you can be there this tour has been so
fun I'm loving it so so much and if you
like this show we only do ads for things
that we actually use and actually love
and the best product the best product
well what I'm saying is if there's one
piece of technology that's changed my
life for the better in the past couple
years it's this if you're watching the
video it's the Apollo neuro it's a piece
of wearable technology that you wear I
wear mine on the inside of the wrist you
can also wear it on your ankle if you
want to be more discreet but it delivers
these almost sub-perceptual vibrations
that speak to your nervous system in the
language that can it can understand
basically giving your body the sensation
of a wearable hug helping you recover
from stress and get that feeling of
being touched or held it can help you
relax it can help you sleep focus and be
more productive using touch therapy to
help you feel safe and in control it's
an absolute Game Changer I have one Val
has one we've gifted Apollos to so many
of our friends it is incredible energy
and wake up is one social is one clear
and focused rebuild and recover great
for after workouts great for after
stressful phone calls or long days at
work calm is one who doesn't want that
it's like finding the fuse box to your
nervous system and you press calm and it
just lulls you into a calm State great
for meditation unwind at night is a
setting unwind and fall asleep if
there's anything better than getting up
in the night peeing and then laying back
down real having a hard time falling
back asleep and realizing you have an
ally you have something on your wrist
that you can push the buttons you don't
have to go on your phone you can push
the buttons and rerun the last program
and it gently lulls you back to sleep
chemical free a pollinuro was developed
by a neuroscientist and a board
certified psychiatrist who've been
studying the impacts of chronic stress
in humans for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies it is not woo-woo
it is science it is incredible and you
can get 10 off at apollonuro.com weird
that's APO llo and uro.com weird do
yourself some support give yourself some
support and support this show
apollonuro.com weird also the product
that has changed my life hugely when it
comes to my brain is on it and Alpha
Brain they make a newer Tropic I've
tried lots of different nootropics there
is none better than Alpha Brain Alpha
what's a nootropic it's like Earth grown
ingredients that help your brain with
Focus memory and concentration if you do
something that involves your brain and
you'd like to do that a little bit more
easily with a little less effort with
more clarity with more concentration
with more dialed in Focus Alpha Brain is
a huge huge Ally a supporter to have in
your corner it's not a stimulant it's
not like caffeine it doesn't get you
jolty just gives your brain the
nutrition it needs to focus and dial in
I use it before I do stand up I use it
before I write I even use it before I go
on a date with Val just have full access
of my brain my personality and my memory
I love it I wish I knew about it in
school I'm so glad I know about it now
so if you do something that involves
your brain chances are you do it's a
wonderful way to show your show some
support
show support to your noodle and also to
the show go to onit.com weirdand news
promo code weird for 10 off everything
you see on that landing page oh and
nit.com weird alright everybody let's
enjoy my dear friend Jay Larson hope you
enjoy get into it
don't do the the shoe storage system
outside of the beach
oh yeah yeah if your shoes are on a
beach towel that your wallet your
Chapstick your phone it's all in the
shoes grab the shoes and go oh it's to
leave it's to escape no I'm saying at
the beach like if this is your amateur
move yeah you're getting pinched quick
it actually makes makes theft easier I
decoy you know what I mean
tell me like I had Beach I had Beach
sunglasses you know what I mean you mean
feel free to steal these sunglasses I
don't want them to be stolen but like
you know like when you get like a nice
pair of sunglasses over time they're
gonna get beat up they're worn down I
have a Lila pair of sunglasses because I
don't know why if I'm wearing a hat or
sunglasses and I pick her up from school
I actually take it as a really good sign
that she's not afraid of me she's not I
don't want that no but our dads did I
mean I know your dad sort of he's really
just taking me down as soon as you get
here but how do you stuck around trust
me he wouldn't have uh he'd want you to
be afraid you'd be afraid yeah you know
what had your dad stuck around he would
have really been a scary guy you know
what I thought about this at um Monday
morning assembly this morning with my
kids at their school they have Monday
morning assembly all the parents are in
front of me two kids fight to the death
the kids have a little MMA just a little
bit yeah by the way real quick because I
know we're not gonna forget Monday
morning assembly Story how could we if
you're watching do you watch session
now I started it and I'm just I slowed
down but I got to get into it right I
know you know do you watch it
we're not even going to talk about last
night but you know the guy what's his
name uh Hugh or something
Hugo has a very thin neck and he works
at ATN a thin neck
[Music]
only Katie liked it every time I see him
I'm like this guy works at ATN this guy
a thin neck all right MMA MMA so the the
principal is the sweetest
most engaging principle I've ever seen
she's this amazing woman and like every
week There's a word of the week and this
week it's honorable and she teaches them
though it in sign language and everyone
does it honorable and I'm just like if I
could go honor
it's unbelievable you see I'm already on
board with this woman she's incredible
right and I'm sitting there I'm like oh
when I was in Elementary School Mr Grant
you wouldn't even you wouldn't even make
eye contact with that guy it was just
fear in your life and my kids principle
is like comes up to you in the hallway
Hi how are you that's so great yeah let
me teach you as well our principal's
like I'm in a suit [__] shut up if
you're in my office you're in trouble my
kids are like no Mrs Fields is going to
go to Mrs Fields office that's it where
she has Mrs Fields cookies I'm assuming
that's all I mean Stacks she her family
founded it is that true no I don't know
where a yes and ends yes ant the Shel
Silverstein book where the yes hand ends
and there's two kids peering over the
edge of a bit Yeah to a fact by the way
shell Silverstein is low-key
hardcore those poems are not like hey
sweet The Giving Tree is that shell yeah
it's like it is like sad and he's in
your face oh yeah Disney is like how can
we rip off from him are they trying no
but like every Disney movie's like all
right let's kill the parents to get this
kid on its way well kids need it kids
love it kids crave it they do they want
it give me someone dead Lilo loves to a
bird flew into one of our windows
and she wanted to put the corpse into a
jar and just watch what happens
it's us it wasn't dead yet oh no it was
long she's like I want to watch it die
Dad we could help
we could help she's sealing the lid
saying to the bird we could help
she puts up a knife as if to poke holes
in the lid this is dark but I'm guessing
it's like Dad well I watch this bird die
will you read Michelle Silverstein ah
see but that's what I'm saying you and I
live in an indoctrinated thought system
where like we've made our peace and it's
just it's a flimsy piece it's a shaky
piece here's things we've made our peace
with that we are fragile impermanent uh
delicate even at risk are you saying us
being adults you and I you and I both
know humans that flashes through your
mind as you brush your teeth sure as my
friend Chris there says as we polish the
bones people can see we polish our bones
so people will like us that's Chris
there's wonderful joke so your mortality
comes up and we bat it away because
that's our thought system we go I know
that's what's happening but get out of
here and then we eat living things and
it doesn't matter if it's a plant or an
animal we know we [__] something up we
[__] up that goddamn we [__] up that
tomato yeah and we said oh you think you
are I am and you eat the [__] tomato
this is the second thought system that
we as grown-ups know and then just sort
of suppress we just act like that's
normal sure you ate something of course
it used to be alive and now you thrive
on its on its energy right and the third
thing is that if you have something you
took it you took it from you're having
it means no one else can have it kids
are new I know you know this they're new
I don't know anything that you're
telling me I love I love how your brain
works I just love that you just break
these down so quickly this is just a
normal thing keep going I'm in but you
love it right because it's true yes what
I'm saying is these are assumptions that
we are so deep in us that we don't even
know totally we're holding on to them
right but kids show up and that's why
they want to put birds in jars is
because they're trying to understand
what death is and moreover they're
trying to understand how we can be in a
place where that's happening and we're
not constantly talking about it totally
by the way can we just cut to you at the
PDA meeting listen kids just want to put
birds in jars guys that's all it is and
they're just like that oh [__] well he's
going dark here they want Bambi's mom to
die yeah they absolutely want Bambi's
mom to die kids are so much more in
touch because they just showed up they
were just dead
they were just dead they were just not
yeah you could say no I like saying
because we look dead is it something
that wasn't living right or was living
then died let's look at it the other way
they just were not yeah and that wasn't
they weren't scared of it it wasn't bad
it wasn't good it just was and there's
so much closer to the the it's the same
door we go in and go out you know what I
mean yeah it's a swinging Cosby kitchen
sitcom door goes this way birth that way
death they just came in so of course
Bambi's mom died it's not a big deal I
know people that have had horrible
tragedies happen in their lives and
their kids are surprisingly chill with
it because they're like I guess that's
just what happens it's us I know that
reality not be a certain way 100 could
it not be dark that it not be fragile
that we will live forever that we are
going to keep going that Elon Musk is
going to go to Mars and we'll find
something up there that if we nibble it
our hair grows back like yeah kids are
like nah or we teach that uh you gotta
be afraid of your parents whereas like
at least that's what we were taught and
now I'm sure you're the same way as me
like we apologize to our kids when we do
something wrong and you know what my
kids do when they do something wrong but
they apologize hit it because that's
what they've seen you know what I mean I
love that if we were in our 20s I would
have got your hand but like with more
body I could have reached yeah no I'm
like beat you know that's why I gave you
the [__] I ran two miles on that I know
I appreciate it you ran I'm not doing a
5k with Reed in May can I ask a quick
question you sure again 5q
five questions about five kids yeah go
for it one why are we counting
kilometers all of a sudden I have no
idea why we do that in anything you know
what I mean why is everyone still
holding on all of a sudden
like the metric system just shows up
because you decided to run
what is a k
5K is like 3.2 miles so it sounds like
more that's why I don't know what it is
there's a 10K a 5k okay imagine if you
were doing three miles bro if you're in
a marathon you're like dude I'm doing a
78k man
see once it's a marathon 28.6 you're
back to Miles twenty Twenty Four Points
20 27 26.2 says 6.2 I'm proud of you bro
that's gonna be up and running I just do
I'm I he likes to run who my son so
that's why we're run I'm doing it I hate
running how old is your son now nine
he's out there running at nine we ran
two 2.5 miles on Saturday and he talks
the whole time and I'm just like yeah I
know and I realize it takes Focus to
listen I'm like I can't because you're
running into garbage can I'm just trying
to run we gotta we got a tracking shot
of you guys you're running towards
camera you definitely clip on some
recycling bins I'm hitting tree branches
that's the opening shot I know how the
Jay lesson dad show which the world
needs the world needs the Jay Larson god
let's get it out there paternal
instincts every way that you're a dad
everything's buddy you're like an
inspiring figure for life and for
parenting because you're like a real yes
you're a real yes guy yeah but with some
weight sure I don't mean physical I know
but just just in case you thought you
got a good slavable foot too by the way
he has a flat bony foot you know I throw
up some nine and a half you know what I
mean
anyway I love the way that you're a dad
you're I I here's my first question for
you yeah is it Peaks and valleys because
when I when I you know I feel bad now in
a moment in this moment going like I
haven't been by your place in a while
but the times that I have it's usually
like I built this hammock there's like
six six different hammocks and if you're
in this one and you fall out while
you're napping you're caught by that one
and this one When You Yank It it plays
the Mario Brothers theme because they
love Mario Brothers and you're building
sheds and Forts and you're that kind of
guy and I love it yeah meaning if you
are afraid you're overcoming it you're
going like everybody's afraid of being
wrong of making The Hammocks wrong of
being stupid of being rejected and
you're like let's go for it anyway yeah
and I'm wondering question number one is
is that a peak Valley situation do you
have times when you go like I can't I
got nothing I'm broken like to build or
like to do activities with them just
like you're it's not so much that you
don't have an idea for it per se but
it's more like you uh just it's just not
happening like the day is maybe it lasts
a couple days we're just like that Jay's
not here right oh yeah
um I don't know I mean we had an amazing
day yesterday and it amazing in like Mom
comes over their mom comes over we do a
Easter egg hunt and then the eh yeah
yeah no yeah
it's still they love it oh JK it's just
eeh spells air yeah Easter egg hunt yeah
all right so we go are you a fan with
what acronym humor I mean you're killing
it today yeah this is like your new
Avenue you've seen Pete's new special
and it's just acronym only the people
that watch it are Mike Kaplan and Zach
Sherwin and they're like this is it and
uh Monday pun day what the hell's Monday
pun day that's his Instagram handle who
is that that's um yeah why am I blank
I'm liking his name right now but he
would he'd love it oh my gosh yeah it's
a certain kind yeah all right so uh your
mom their mom comes up Mom comes over we
do the Easter egg hunt then we just hang
out for the day for four hours the fam
yeah she comes over I make breakfast for
everybody can I say that since we talked
last time you are no longer married yeah
of course divorced but here you're still
doing family units oh yeah of course
yeah of course yeah I know I know you
know I'm a guard component yeah
uh we we we do a great job co-parenting
she does an amazing job I give her tons
of credit she's a bumper sticker that
says Kate is my co-parent
this is my co-parent you're the only
person that could say that that Kate
would like laugh and be like Pete that's
a piece she would love it yeah listening
to this I don't know why she's smoking
no but um and so then like like she's
hanging out in the kids rooms you know
what I mean which is nice they love that
you know like when you're divorced
you're you never like any time I go to
her house and kick it a little bit I
always hang in like their rooms I'm like
laying their bed I'm like what's it like
in here for you you know what I mean
yeah it's so fun this is great Mary J
Larson owning it yeah owning Bambi died
you know what I mean kids want of course
Don't Look Away not only do they got a
divorce let's own it right tell them yes
I'll never forget so my mom and brother
don't talk right so I'm home for
Christmas last year or which not not 20
20 21. and we I'm going into Boston to
see my brother with my kids and my
daughter's sitting on the floor tying
her shoes and she looks at my mom and
she goes why aren't you coming to see
Uncle Adam and she goes well I have
things to do blah blah and my daughter
stated her and then she tied her shoes
and walked away and I looked at my mom
and she goes she knows you just lied to
her and she goes what I go you just lied
to her and she knows it she knows you
don't talk to Uncle Adam and she asked
you because she wanted to see what you
would say because kids ask us for
Direction they ask questions so that
they can get guidance so they can know
things look at this black church hand
that just went up involuntarily because
I'm loving it yeah and that's what they
do in every aspect so the more you can
be honest and real with them yes and I
mean questions you know you can skirt
you can skirt like my son asked
yesterday he goes so the Easter Bunny
we're like waiting for their mom to come
over for the Easter egg hunt she goes
that my daughter was like so the Easter
Bunny just comes over and puts eggs out
for everyone I'm like yeah and then my
son goes or maybe it's the Easter Bunny
or maybe it's you and I was like yeah
and I just was like I'm not answering
this without talking to their mom first
um where I know we're running 2.2 a day
chatting the whole time we still believe
it in the bun bun
sweetheart real quick where are we on
the bun
Nies little mini David Goggins over here
asking me about the bun bun he's running
with a broken hernia I don't know what a
hernia is I think it's a bone
um can I say real quick because we're
going to stay on this I love laying in
the bed yeah it continues to this day my
mom was telling me she wanted me to come
home for a certain family event and then
she sort of let it slip that the main
reason was because she was being made to
feel guilty by another family member
that she wasn't doing enough to make a
big deal out of this family event so she
thought if I came it would instead and
Val and I were talking about it we were
like that's an opportunity to go like
you know you're on blah blah blah is
making me feel guilty and I think it's
to try and maybe get you to come but
that's not how we work we don't respond
to fear we don't really like I'm not
going to let someone guilt me into
guilting you can you imagine if my mom
if my mom said that she was like she's
guilting me so I'll guilt you but the
only thing that comes from that is hurt
and resentment so if you want to come it
would be beautiful but we're not doing
it for her in fact we're not even
inviting her you know what I mean like
like that would be it continues I'm
still being parented it doesn't get in
as much that's my parents no I know it's
horrible bear it's horrible it's like hi
I someone has a gun to my head can I put
a gun to your head dude [__] no
[__] how about we get out of this
hostage situation yeah and live our
lives because we die one day do we want
to be in a hospital going like high
forced people who forced me to do things
when I was forced that's your that's it
that's what you're teaching me it's my
favorite thing to do is when my mom
continues to talk the way she talked to
us to my kids I jump right in I go don't
listen to her what's she saying that's
not how we talk that's like she was just
out here and she just this is this it's
this simple and this is for everyone out
there it is this simple my mother all
the lovers my mother said to my son she
wanted him to get a chair from the other
room for me to sit in I didn't ask for
it
haven't even gotten there and I just
there's three chairs at the table
because I have two children and myself
and we're in the kitchen my mother was
in town she came over to have breakfast
I make breakfast I'm Gonna Stand I'm
drinking coffee you know I'm not eating
I just want to stand I wanted her to be
with my kids yes take my chair and she
goes to my son it would be nice of you
to get a chair from the other room for
your dad
and I go I go I'm good buddy I don't
need a chair and then after they left I
go do you know what you said to him and
I go you said to him if you don't get a
chair you're not nice that is what you
just said yeah I go why can't you just
say hey Reid would you grab me a chair
from the other room please you know what
he'll do he'll go sure and he'll go get
it because we're not putting [__]
around these questions
how about it would make your mother
happy oh if you called more
what is this that's saying I don't have
the ability to call you and be
vulnerable to let you know that I miss
you can I tell you how many times I've
been like it goes both ways these these
aren't Ham radios I don't know how I am
radios
Morse code guys exactly there you go
Morse code you can't reply to a morse
code no yeah you can yeah you can be a
flashlight yeah you can with a
flashlight yeah whatever it is it's not
a one-way communication but that that's
asking for so much health and healing to
come in going like stop it's deep
codependence is what it is it's like of
course I have to bite my tongue when I
want to say to Leela and I do I do want
to say when you hug me it makes me happy
like because you know she hugs me and it
makes me feel happy but I don't want her
to go around going like well now I if I
don't hug him Dad's on him I am the CEO
of Dad's feelings
[__] that that's why I've always wanted
to do this bed where I get mad about
Mark Wahlberg saying everything I do is
for my kids I'm like dude you have 50
billion dollars it's not for your kids
and I want to say on stage Leela I'm not
doing this for you this is for Daddy
yeah this is for Daddy and that would be
very meaningful to me to be like let's
get honest Bambi's mom is dead I wasn't
he doesn't need a chair a lot of me
being a great dad is for me
I I didn't have a dad and I wanted to
give to what am I doing to kids to be
dads you know what I mean I want them to
see what it feels like but that what
look I can't know but it seems like a
lot of the old school parenting style
was like I'm parenting you and you're
incurring a debt oh yeah this this will
I'm paying into a bond my mother would
say to us like well you know when I'm
older you're gonna have to take care of
me you know and stuff like that like it
was just all this constant fear guilt I
mean that's not everyone you see people
that have like
I don't think my ex's parents were like
that her my in-laws are amazing people
and they're really cool and Val's
parents aren't this way and we are both
from Boston I can't say it's a Boston
thing I don't think it's I have other
friends that their parents are like dope
you know what I mean yeah and I'm not
saying my mom's not dope she's an
incredi all my brothers and sisters we
kind of say the same thing like except
the one that doesn't talk to her right
no but he would say this too really that
she is Super Rad funny interesting
person great to have as a friend great
friend great friend
she's fun every one of my friends Mom
you're a great friend yeah end of list
and not for me
but every one of my friends like dude
what are you talking about your mom's so
and I'm like yeah she's a great hang
yeah she's a fun hang my a guy I started
with his name was Nathan his name still
is Nathan trenholm had a bit I don't
remember the wording but it was like
when you confused your kid your friends
parents who's an alcoholic and you just
think he's fun yeah and I was like that
Rings true for like a lot of my child
not just my family but like other
families I knew like the Wild guy that's
like keeping beers in the fish tank
like he seems like a hoot guys this
guy's a [__] hoot he keeps giving us
pizza we already had pizza he ordered
another Pizza I'm trying to think if I
had any I don't think I had any friends
whose dads or parents were alcoholics
there was one dude some shady dude who
lived in a back house and at like two
yards over and I say that because we
would go through backyards to get to
Sean Donovan and Sean Dunham would have
a black I remember had a black eye one
day and then we were playing a board
game in his living room and his dad or
stepdad can't remember was in the
bedroom with his wife Sean's mom or girl
whatever it was and was like keep it
down out there everyone's gonna have
black eyes and we're just looking you
know Sean's crazy dad I didn't have a
dad he's ripping on the black eye yeah
he's using what he sees and no and then
somebody's like is he making what he
sees that's what I'm saying we never
knew yeah what a nightmare yeah a true
nightmare all right so you're you're
sleeping in your kids beds you're
getting all involved yeah so then
because bammy's Mom is Dad and Mom and
Dad aren't together anymore they know
know that they know it not only do they
know it for you when I FaceTime this is
the coolest thing ever when I FaceTime
my son the other day this is like a week
ago I FaceTime I talked to my son I talk
to my daughter and then my son takes the
phone he goes okay here's your ex and
hands the phone to my ex here's your ex
and that's how and I love it and I think
it's his your ex it's it's great not
here's mom no here's your ex you know
and I was like he says it because he
wants to call it out in front of us to
see how we're gonna react blood in the
water he wants to see how we're gonna
react yeah he's he's calling he's naming
reality so much of what we do as
grown-ups this goes back to what I was
saying at the beginning is resisting and
re-labeling reality yeah yeah yeah and
that's that's even me being pressured
into the family event it's like let's
give appearances that it looks like
we're healthy in this way who because
who cares if we actually are yeah but
it's so much healthier and that's the
best moments in my family are when we're
actually like roasting each other and
getting real and being real yeah like I
remember my dad made my dad laughed so
hard where he was like you know I I
never drank that much and we were little
Doms and I went oh yeah Dad one or two
one or two just a white wine with dinner
and my brother looked like he looked
like he was leaving his body he was so
scared yeah but then my dad started
dying laughing and I was like this
that's what comedy is yeah and that's
what kids are it's like here's your ex
is comedy and you know what pain is
here's mom to you yes he's still it's
still you guys you guys yeah the other
day so that Kate's my ex is over we're
in the garage and I got the they always
have the door up we have this giant Lego
table in there and we're playing Legos
and the neighbor the table is made of
Legos or the table is Four Legos it's
Four Legos be clear please thank you
just kidding eight foot by three and a
half feet I made it uh that's more
there's my boy you know what I mean yeah
they love it and so there's this
Neighbor Next Door he's got two Bernice
Mountain Dogs giant dogs and he comes by
and every time the kids or my daughter
will go out and play with the dogs the
dogs love the kids he loves my kids
my daughter will climb this tree next to
their fence and like talk over the fence
to him and like pet the cat with no
improvement yeah yeah exactly you can
never see his face
so that he stops and my ex is there you
know and I'm like oh I go this is Kate
have you guys ever met and he's like no
and then my son goes their ex his ex
that's his ex and I go yeah I go this is
my ex-wife you know and she goes yeah
and then like we just called it out to
him yeah like yeah I don't know I think
sometimes my son is challenging us yeah
to be like you want us to be cool with
this let's be cool with it and I'm just
like yup all day bro you said it was
okay
prove it let's be okay prove it I know
how many kids do you know
oh sorry whose parents were divorced and
they say that everyone says the same
story
you know when you're a divorced kid like
I am like my parents were divorced but
my dad bounced and he was just gone but
everyone else that I ever met whose
parents divorced they said the same
thing our parents sat us down they had
one conversation they never brought it
up again right and as was their way yes
and I said I never wanted that to be the
case yeah never
um I don't know and when I say trauma I
just mean A disruption like a huge
disruption of what you thought was going
on so please don't feel like I'm shaming
or victimizing or anything familiar with
what trauma is yeah I know but it's in
that capacity yeah some people might
think it's a judgment it's not a
judgment but anything any disruption
let's say that who who solves it in one
one chat and you're a kid
and then of course you go to the weird
bully at the school who whose parents
are also divorced and he's like your
dad's gonna start having sex with other
people like you get it from him yeah
totally with the rat tail yeah and he's
good at yo-yo
oh guess what next thing you know your
dad's gonna have a girlfriend she's
gonna wanna kiss you you know like stuff
like that crazy stuff but get it from
you I talked to my kids grow a rat tail
you get good at the yo-yo I know I
always wanted that rat tail but I never
graded one you did oh yeah oh my god of
course you did of course I mean you and
Adam Nebraska who Adam Raska my kid
buddy growing up what's up Adam he had a
rat tail he looked good in it like a
Theo Von kind of sexy rat too no Theo's
got the full mullet no I know he's got
it's not a It's Like an Eagle Tail yeah
it's like a full feathered yeah yeah
um but so he would say that
um about the divorce but like so I will
continue to have conversations because
for a while during the divorce the kids
would say like I don't like having two
houses you know every now and then about
like a month and a half ago my daughter
I was putting her to bed and she goes
will you sing me a song and I go yeah so
we're laying there I usually tell them
stories and I start singing the song she
goes sing me the song you'd sing to me
when I was a kid so I started singing I
used to sing good night sweetheart well
it's you know that song Three Men and a
Baby exactly she starts singing it with
me right so is she doing the bass no I
do that
I go deep into it but she's singing it
with me and then she stops and she just
she had one arm around me she puts her
other arm up around me and then goes I
miss when you and Mom were together
had never said that had always used to
say I miss having two houses but it was
the first time she said YouTube yeah
I'm you two together yeah and I was just
like oh yeah that's got to be tough for
you huh is that is that hard for you
sometimes you still think about that
tell me about it and we just talk about
it because so much of like what
parenting is or should be is and our we
used to have a child psychologist that
would tell us this your kids don't want
you to solve their problem they just
want you to hear them acknowledge that
they're having a feeling they don't want
you to be like well it's okay because
well they just want you to go oh yeah
the way that it's better
you keep singing don't worry
style that's what we're doing now yeah
big feeling yeah like Leela uh will want
mama if Mama spent the night in LA or
something and she wakes up in the
morning she's like I miss Mom and I'm
like me too man I miss Mom my mama's the
best yeah what do you love about Mama
yeah she's like exactly she's beautiful
I say that too she's them about their
divorce and we're divorced I go I know
your mom's great tell me and then every
time I'm teaching them that because
something ends doesn't mean it's a
failure and you're teaching them not to
be addicts basically that if you end
something now I hate them yeah oh yeah
that's evil yeah he's my dad's voice
that's evil now yeah that's true Forge
the earth I love that your dad has a
dead tongue your tongue
Peter I can't feel my time
he's just always coming home from the
dentist what is going on well you know I
projected on to my dad but really it's
me I I have that black I'm tempted to
Black or White thinking if I decide
someone isn't for me this isn't me this
isn't highest Pete but there's a part of
Pete that will go like that person's not
safe and then my my ego or whatever you
want to call it just goes like we're on
it and they'll build a case and every
time that person comes up they'll open
the folder and go like oh don't forget
these things and that's how it keeps
that person that I'm afraid of away from
me so here you have your ex very
tempting to be like I miss mommy well
I'm glad one of us does yeah why not
just yeah I I mean yesterday I even said
I go I forget what I was telling him I
go oh my gosh I go guys your mom when we
first started dating and I just tell him
stories I'm like I'm always going to
tell them stories can I can I tell you
something yeah can I can I interrupt
yeah of course did I interrupt I mean
you you have a bunch so far yeah no I
know I feel like I definitely feel that
yeah but am I interrupting no I don't
care where am I going I'm gonna where am
I going I'm on your couch and there's
two nice lights we got new lights out
there beautifulness that beautiful new
set we got the skyline uh
I'm in church I've told the story on we
made it weird but I don't think I've
ever told on you made it weird but it's
almost over if anyone's heard it before
I'm in church and there was this guy one
of the volunteers teaching Sunday school
he looked like Andre the Giant but with
like a shock of beautiful gray hair and
his name was Bobby and his hands look
like catcher's mitts and he's just a
giant man and he and he was just a giant
man beautiful man beautiful big hands
made my weiner looks so small
anyway he goes trust me after church
today go up to your father say go kiss
your mom go kiss ma like you used to and
he'll go and he'll love it and she'll
love it and I'm over here going like I
don't think they've ever done that even
like when they were dating so like
losing that
idea that your parents ever liked each
it's important yeah I'm just yes ending
that you are for sure loved whether
they're married or not that's a really
good point yeah it's a beautiful thing I
and that's funny because I never was
modeled you know my dad wasn't in my
home and then the only other couple that
I was around a lot was like my high
school girlfriends and they never I
never watched them kiss or anything like
that you know like I think it's a
so I mean you might not see it at all
but I always love to recount to them all
the great things about their mom yeah I
mean yeah and how do you I mean is that
do you I would use the word love you
still love
I mean I'll always I love who she is I
think she's great I think she's awesome
you know just the relationship yeah but
like um yeah I mean I have love for her
for sure you know what I mean she's like
it's funny I've been writing an email to
her all her her
brother and sister and their husbands
and wives because I haven't talked to
any of them since the divorce and I'm
like I'm done with this I'm sending an
email and letting them know hey you know
I haven't talked to you and I just want
to let you know so that there's no
misconception I will always approach you
with an open heart and my house is
always opening you if you ever want to
FaceTime the kids when they're with me
or you're in town and the kids are with
me and you you can come to my house like
because you got six hammocks we gotta
hammock for everybody
you know just because I'm like I don't
want anyone to have misconception
because when I was a kid and your
parents got divorced then there were
aunts and uncles I didn't talk to for 25
years because they just stood in the
divorce they got lot yeah and I was
telling them like hey if you think
that's the case it's not you know as a
divorce person that just lost the
friends like they're gone yeah family
they're gone yeah yeah so we're it's a
weird [__] thing yeah what how open
are you being because you and I have
talked off about kind of what went Rocky
on your side of things yeah
I'm not super open about it talk about
it
well you know what it is it's like talk
about it explicitly you're a divorce guy
yeah and people people always want to go
what happened and it's like something
you're like do you think there was like
uh this isn't like 911 yeah you know
what I mean what happened pre-9 like
what are all the things that led up to
it you know right and it's hard for some
people people when when they ask that to
me sometimes
I think it's more of people kind of
wanting like a gossip point of course
something to like oh my God bite into
you know uh comedy couples going through
the divorcee and and you see we are our
own 24-hour news cycle yeah and we want
it reduced into a banner yeah and it's
like did you hear the story and we love
it and it really especially because
marriage is such a precarious thing I
don't I wouldn't say I feel precarious
but I'm also a divorced person that I'm
aware that it's a it's a thing it's it's
like us yeah it's like us we're daisies
in a field we'd like to think we're
Turtles but we're daisies yeah and
relationships are also daisies and you
can do your best to protect but they're
always going to be a little fragile yeah
so when another marriage goes down it's
a perfect opportunity to project onto
that whatever evil you don't want to
look at in yourself so you hear the
story and you go well that's them that's
them not us not us not us it's another
kind of tool for denial if that makes
sense those feelings that are too big to
feel you project so when somebody gets
divorced you project it onto them and
you go we're good though they're they're
the dumb [__] so that's what people are
sniffing out with there's also like um
some people don't want to talk to other
people other people just completely
never want to talk to you again because
it's like the guys might be like someone
broke this down to me this like divorced
Dad we were golfing and someone Madrigal
actually was like you should golf with
my buddy I want you to golf with him
he's divorced you know what I mean
annual divorce dates yeah and it was the
guy was great he goes you're gonna have
to understand something man he goes
there are couples that are rocky right
now and the the man
the woman doesn't want to be around you
because you're free the guy doesn't want
to be around you because he's like
afraid to even taste like or get a sense
of like what you mean the voices yeah
the divorce person yeah you're the
Pariah yeah exactly danger the the the
guy who's divorced I remember when I got
divorced I told this other guy about how
great it was my wife left me and it
wasn't great right away but like a year
later I was kind of feeling like this is
incredible I was missing out on all this
life and I remember he was like you
realized I got married because you told
me that if you have sex before marriage
we go to hell right like you're a huge
reason why I got married so the fact
that you're over there smoking cools and
like riding on Wheelie sneakers and
having uh casual sex like that's driving
me crazy so yeah you're a threat yeah
you become a splinter yeah in the whole
thing yeah that's that that can um
throw people a little bit but you golfed
with divorce Dad yeah and he was just
he's the one who broke that down for me
I was like oh yeah because I've had
friends that you just all casually they
slide away and you don't talk to them
anymore because
you know at the end of the day too if
you look at it couples with kids you're
a couple with kids right you have how
many play dates are you gonna make you
know what I mean and then are they gonna
make a play date with my ex and the kids
and me and the kids at some point
they're gonna be like all right it's
enough who are we gonna do the play date
with you know what I mean so like
there's that and then I've had friends
straight up email me and be like yo I'm
out like I'm just yeah I just don't want
to be your friend anymore and I'm like
I'm not saying it's from the divorce but
you're like could be I have another
friend that I did that to because of my
divorce I was like
I just I I'd like realized I wanted more
from this friendship than had been there
in a long time and when I was going
through all the pain of the divorce this
person was incapable and I'm like yo man
I'm out like oh you realized you were
ringing the bell too much yeah yeah
interesting and so I was I've been on
both sides of it you know why why send
the email why not just ghost and toast
like somebody felt they had to email you
and go like just so you know well I mean
we were friends for 20 years I married
them wow you married Nick Swardson
Sports and bearing uh Jolly I'm trying
to guess who it is this dude you don't
know this guy I married him I used to be
roommates with him like we were friends
a long time we were roommates with
Nicktoon yeah
[Music]
I want to see them tonight for dinner
trying to guess
um no it's not it's not because it was
it was there was so much history he felt
like he had to say that's good I guess I
mean yeah I like to I in my friend I
called and I had the conversation I was
just like listen this is what's been
going on and I feel like I just wanted
to call you and I married him as well
he's still married yeah anything maybe
it was that like you're a free agent
acid kind of guy no he was he was very
close with my family and my kids and
there were days that like I would go by
to drop something off for the kids when
it was new and he was there playing with
my kids and I would like I would I'd
have to leave and I was bawling you know
what I mean I'd go home and cry alone
and he wouldn't call he wouldn't text
nothing he wouldn't check in on me and
that happened twice Andy had only come
to my house like once and I was just
like I was devastated I thought we were
I got him a lot of work I had like got
him his house I married him and I will
say to see my side of the the coin here
when I told him everything he was like I
know I know I didn't know what to do I
can be a better friend and he he really
owned it but I was so mentally prepared
to say that like this was going to be
like when you break it off yeah that I
just stuck with it and he still my kids
still see him and stuff like that which
is tough you know that's right but you
just kind of that's just what it is you
know I once came home in this house and
Val was just cooking dinner with a guy
friend of ours and I talked about it in
therapy
you know what Dr Gary Penn said he goes
it's not like it was wrong or bad it
just was the wrong Optics yeah use the
term Optics yeah and I was like that was
the wrong optic yeah
it just felt so like sometimes we all
have different strength levels yeah
different vulnerability levels and I was
vulnerable and I saw it I'm just
relating so you're seeing that I
completely understand why you would ball
on your car it's incredibly tell me a
little bit instead of telling me about
that juicy stuff I wanted you to tell me
about
JK
um tell me about the therapist that you
found who goes into the ocean every
morning and everything everything he
taught you oh my God because don't you
have this incredible yeah Mentor that
guy just carried me through yeah so much
stuff yeah
um unload give the people all the stuff
you paid for give it to them for free I
mean I'm trying to think like there's so
many things that he would say I can't
take one single I think the main thing
that I took away from him how did you
find him
through a friend of a friend you know a
friend of a friend and he's a therapist
yup big white beard no not licensed I
don't know if he's licensed or not he's
just a life coach he's just like a life
coach yeah okay and he he's just like
one of those guys that's been through so
much I guess and just has so much depth
that like he just sees things
immediately you know what I mean and
cause like yeah and labels it yeah so so
much negative self-talk that I had he
took away from me like taught me how to
though this is the one thing that I
think people may have heard
inner child work you know people always
hear inner child or inner child yeah you
told me about this you're a picture of
you yeah and this is something tell the
people yeah I will I will this is
something so your inner child right is
alive constantly you never it really
never changes it's always your inner
child like so those some people stops
growing I don't I don't really know to
be honest as much about that but what
I've come to understand about myself and
my inner child is my inner child has
been scared out of its [__] brains
from Jump Street you know I mean why do
we drive past my dad's street and I
don't see him for years like five times
a week we drive by his street and I
wouldn't happen what do you mean what do
you mean what do I mean who's driving by
that you you my father lived the town
over from us and on the way to my
grandmother's house you would pass my
dad's street oh and we didn't see him
right so by the time I was like nine or
ten we stopped seeing my dad all
together that was it no communication
nothing to the fact that I didn't talk
to him again until I was 20 5 from 10
and then didn't see him till I was 36. I
saw him one day when I was 36. not on my
birthday but anyway so like every day we
drive by his street and but not talk
about it oh there was nothing to be said
no my mother no no one and we would just
drive by it and I just [__] would
shrink and feel like this tiny little
you were re-traumatized yeah I felt like
I'm nothing I'm nobody why doesn't that
man love why don't I talk to him why
does no one bring this up why am I so
alone I've talked to my brother about it
he's like yeah I was going through the
same thing you know I mean can we take
another route
there's only one Street in hey MapQuest
it's uh she lives in a cul-de-sac
double gold no I'm just kidding there is
only one Street in and you would Pat
it's crazy so wow when I started working
with this therapist he started doing
some inner child work with me and what
we did was we would take I would I took
three pictures of myself as a kid and I
put them on my wall and I would go up to
them and I would say to the picture like
you're gonna be okay I'll stand up for
you I got you I love you you're smart I
would do positive information it's this
little tiny baby yeah and which would
then go to my inner child like I didn't
it's you it feels weird and odd to even
talk about
it does not I love everything oh I know
you do but I'm saying like when I first
thought about it I'm like how is that
going to get to the inner child I I've
done the same thing I'm just so you feel
like I'll do I'll look at myself in the
mirror and say it to myself in the
mirror yeah and if I feel a little bit
off course it's usually corrected by
something like that yeah like just like
lean in
your unconscious deals and symbols you
know what I mean trying to talk to your
unconscious in English is is is like
talking to a calculator and yeah English
I was like where is he Peak very doesn't
very often come down to dead end you
know what I mean but I thought it'd be I
could have done it but I thought it was
funny to kind of end on a like a weak
fart yeah but like the only way to to uh
talk to your unconscious is through
these symbols so these photographs of
your children or looking at yourself in
the mirror like get some pictures
involved yeah yeah you know what I mean
I think that's I'm not a vision board
person but I think that's what's going
on with vision yeah it's like let's
let's see it let's see it because
otherwise we don't know what we're
talking about if you just go success it
doesn't know what you're talking about
and again I don't know about manifesting
or any of that but I do believe that you
sang to little Jay I got you is way more
valuable and more powerful than just
saying inner child I got you like it
steps you gotta step into the dad role
to be honest with you it was me being a
dad to myself like you daded yourself
yeah and then it's beautiful when I went
home that Christmas that I told you my
mom said to my my daughter I was like
you know she knows you're lying that's
same trip home my therapist is like I
want you to do something if you're up to
and I go I'm up for whatever bro and he
goes I want you to go to your dad's
house I Want You To Burn It to the
Ground
I don't know if you have four it's arson
you give me Jay arson
um
and I was like you kind of hated it with
Jay arson no I used to get grand larceny
that was a nickname that I had for a
minute I sometimes call Childish Gambino
mild fish branzino
branzino's such a good fish is there a
mild mild branzino
they see that what about a bridge it's
just a brick it's just a sea bass he
said go to your father's house park out
front uh-huh and just sit in the car and
let it all go like let him go release
him release all that pain let your inner
child know you're there you got this
yeah you're with him now yes you're not
alone nope you're with you yeah a
hundred you're with Jay six when I say
six hammock it sounds like I'm making
fun of you you're that guy totally
you're in your kids beds you're you're
telling your daughter you're you're
Fielding some pretty goofy fly balls
from your kids read your divorce yeah
you're doing the work you're finding
help you're resourced now you both go
sit in front of your dad's house not
alone no a whole a whole group a whole
Council yeah all the different J's yeah
um let's go I want to go back to the bed
thing I thought you were like let's go
to the mid-rolls I'm like go thank you
yeah you can host
um at some point I want to tell you
about a thing with the bed but so and I
just sat there and I thought I was going
to be like oh I there was no fear in it
I was just like said to my family I'm
like hey I gotta go run an errand can
you can everyone's cool with the kids
they're like yeah and I just went I
didn't cry I thought I was gonna like
lose it and ball nothing it was just
like all right here we go this is great
I got it and it was just like a whole
other level of it it felt amazing so you
sat and you parked
if you're like me when I do those things
it's never what you expect you like you
said you forecasted tears oh yeah
exactly and then what was it was it more
so surprised it was just like a calm and
I was like oh wow like I didn't have to
like hate him I didn't have to blame him
I could just like accept him for having
faults and then my inner child it was my
inner child that was okay
I was already like done the work on this
but then I had never done all that inner
child stuff so like they you know every
it was like the whole group it was like
the jury was no longer a hung jury you
know like you said all the people when I
say I'm proud of you it's not from a
place I know it's on the same level cool
but I can be proud of you yeah even
though we're on the exact same level
yeah it's from that place I appreciate
that grabbing an award from my special
and giving it to you I'm just
acknowledging yeah what a what a feat
that you've done huge win yeah yeah yeah
and that you the the thing about the
ocean not that it's about this but you
told me that he was did he get you into
that stuff like changing your routine
your morning routine oh well morning
routine is huge tell me for him it's
morning routine for him no that's like
one of him one of his main things that
he preaches always is morning routine
right and has that bled into Jay a
hundred tell me so he he's like hardcore
like you'll see on his Instagram like
he's up at 4 30 the candle lit gratitude
list he's up crazy early and he jumps in
the ocean every day 365 days a year to
shock a system get on the way I always
looked at it is like to get comfortable
in the uncomfortable that's like a big
part of him like therapy is like be
comfortable in the uncomfortable it's
literally a trauma it's a physical
trauma it's and I was seeing something
about cold exposure sorry everybody
listening we're going to keep it brief
on codex we talk a lot about cold
exposure on this thing yeah but it's
like your heart
one of the things that is so dangerous
is your heart not being adaptive to like
shock yeah and like so it's like getting
comfortable psychologically getting
comfortable in discomfort recognizing
that pleasure is on the other side of
pain I I know I say this but I'm gonna
say that every time I think of it human
beings as animals will do way more that
to avoid pain than they will to pursue
pleasure yeah and that is one of the
biggest
traps of being alive is that you're like
I could do like you running or whatever
whatever your sacrifices or your your
disciplines are you know there's
something greater on the other side of
it resist for me resisting I ate dinner
at like 4 45 yesterday so you know when
I was watching succession having a panic
attack last night I wanted to Salve my
Panic with some [__] fritas that we
had from a family visit didn't need them
because I knew the satisfaction in the
morning would be greater than the Fritos
but these are these are like secrets of
the universe stuff nobody knows this so
this dude's jumping in the ocean because
he knows it yeah well he's yeah he
that's the thing he does and uh so his
morning routine you know so I what I do
in the morning is I get up I meditate I
do like TM so I do TM in the morning and
then depending on how good I am on my
morning routine like this morning I just
got up and I meditated that was it other
days I'll get up I'll meditate I do I
also do positive affirmations you know
what I mean I'll do gratitude dudes I do
gratitudes every night when I go to bed
I just lay in bed and I say them out
loud and I just have a talk with what
you might think is like a god or higher
power but it's more just like with
myself like it's the counsel you're
talking about yeah and I laugh at like
the things about my kids there is I say
to my kids all the time our family's
motto is this a solution for everything
like we never my kids are like Zen man
they don't get like worked up and we
just always I'm like this is a solution
like whatever what you're whatever is
going on right now there is a solution
here and anytime something's I go what
do we always say and they'll be like
there's a solution for and it's insane
to watch them like do the same thing
it's very Fred Rogers if it's
mentionable it's manageable it's sort of
the emotional version of I love that by
the way just another compliment coming
your way
moms and dads can do this so when I say
it's Dad energy I just really just mean
it's like um
I don't know it's masculine it's like
there's a decisiveness I don't know how
to has nothing to do with the gender but
there's something about saying if that
happens we'll deal with it you know what
I mean that is a gift that that I
that one one parent needs to be giving
is the person that goes like yeah it's
chaos out there yeah we'll deal with
that if it happens yeah we'll deal with
that and this and you know what another
thing people there's there's one thing
that parents say that I kind of
uh it's not that I can't stand it I just
have never said it I've never felt it
and maybe I'm maybe I will some point I
don't know but I've never said it goes
so fast I've never said it yeah and it's
and I honestly don't feel it I feel like
I'm maybe it's because I'm just so into
whatever they're in and maybe when
they're 21 I'm gonna be like oh my God
what I don't know but um I'm always just
like present for whatever is happening
and it feels good to be okay with it but
I prep them I'm already starting to prep
them and I go I'm not always going to be
here you know what I mean like
if I have like a lot of work coming up
I'll be like so you know in a couple
months I'm just not gonna be I have to
go do work I keep them involved and
not the decisions but what's going to
happen I tell them that like yeah at
some point I'm probably gonna date you
know you never know I might get married
again I might marry someone who's got
kids and you guys have are going to have
brothers or sisters and they're like oh
my God I never forget one day I had that
conversation with the kids and I go yeah
and I go mom mom might remarry and marry
someone who has kids and then my son
goes what if Mom marries another woman
and then I go yeah and he goes then
we'll have three moms if you marry I'm
like yeah and he goes wow and they go
what if we get kids and I have this
whole conversation like and I text the
whole thing to my ex I'm like this is
what we talked about you know like when
we go through these like crazy
conversations project three moms is
greenlit
just we're gonna be swimming in moms man
hey to my ex not sure what you're vibing
but the kids would love it if you get
into what are you about another woman if
that was your thing
um
Yeah man so the inner child stuff all
from in the morning
I love this my kids will get up and come
in while I'm meditating yeah and they
come in and I'll just like open eye and
I go hey buddy and they go hey Dad and I
go I'm almost done and they'll just like
lay in my bed while I meditate they sit
in a room on a midday versus like you
know what what we may have grown up
around
and it's also just pure fear we're back
to my daughter taking my hat and glasses
I love it I'm like yeah don't be afraid
of me I I I people laugh at me because I
say to my daughter all the time what's
mine is yours and they're like wait till
she's 16 and she wants the car yeah well
yeah she can't have the car if I need
the car but well you know what I know
I'd love that when she's 16 I'm able to
get her a car yeah or teacher I want to
start I've already started teaching no
one taught me about money so we're
already we already learned about money
in my house you know I mean hey this is
like I always tell them I go when you
earn a dollar you don't really earn a
dollar you know you're earning 50 Cent
sense and I say that because you're
gonna have to save some the government
takes some you know like we work through
it yeah to the point where instead of
having a lemonade stand I keep like a t
coffee tin and a T10 and like they each
have like cash in there you know what I
mean like if they get like if someone
sells them Valentine's Day money we put
it in there and anyway so one day I was
like we're gonna do a flower stand and
they go okay and I go I took forty
dollars out of each of their ten they
never spend the tin it's just there yeah
so we had 80 bucks we went to the Flower
Mart in downtown Los Angeles and we
spent 80 on flowers came back made
bouquets set up a flower stand put out
signs we did a this is where our cost
this is what we're gonna charge we have
this many bouquets there's so much we
can make
and then we sold them right each kid
made their 40 back plus 32 bucks so we
made double their money doubled their
money almost and I'm like this is what
we did and then I gave them each a cut
I'm like now if this if you were taxed
on this then now I'm a finder's fee
whose idea was it ten percent yeah and
then like we went to the store and they
got to like use some of that money and I
was like oh those are the little
activities for me that like you can
learn about flower arranging which are
things I learned from my mom that we can
learn about business a little bit it's
an activity we go to explore downtown
where they got to go up to people and
ask them for flowers and ask how much
they cost and it was just that's that's
the [__] I get down on if I could just
get paid to be a dad like that that's
all I would do you know wow it's rad I'm
just really impressed
pardon the interruption weirdos one of
the simplest and smallest things that
has added so much value to our lives is
cooking together as a family and with a
four-year-old we've even noticed that
when we allow our daughter into the
preparation of the meal she is so much
more likely to try it and even try new
foods and Val and I are now in love with
the best looking best cooking new cook
and bakeware from Caraway they have no
nasty chemicals they're easy to clean
fun to use the food slides right off the
plate without anything disgusting hiding
in the chemicals which is wonderful
whether you're late to spring cleaning
or just about to do some anytime
cleaning they're thoughtfully designed
sets and complementary storage makes
getting and staying organized easier
than ever and you can now save 10 off
the full Suite of Caraway products from
their internet famous cookware to their
newly launched food storage set care
Way's high quality ceramic coating
kitchenware is free of PTFE e such as
Teflon lead cadmium I hope I'm saying
that right and other toxic materials so
you know you're cooking safe but I don't
have to say it right because it's not in
my life anymore we're not just using
random stuff at the store we're using
Caraway which is the best of the best
their kitchenware comes in a variety of
chic Shades we got like a beautiful
light cream color that really adds to
the beauty of our kitchen and all sets
include complementary easy access
storage solution ceramic is naturally
slick in the surface which means minimal
oil or butter for a slide off the pan
eggs and super super easy cleaning I
love the Slick surface and I love that
it means I can use less oil and less fat
when I'm cooking and we got that
beautiful color and it's beautiful and
easy to clean I mean you can't ask for
anything better and it gets us cooking
more in the kitchen together and over 40
000 people have raved about their
Caraway kitchen now it's time for you to
try it yourself and support this show
visit
carawayhome.com weird to take advantage
of this limited time offer for 10 off
your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for a weirdo so visit Caraway
c-a-r-a-w-a-y home
h-o-m-e.com slash weird and use code
weird at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern
it's also brought to us this episode by
our friends you know this at next Evo my
absolute favorite life-changing
game-changing CBD brand whenever I buy
something I always do my research I'm
one of those people especially if it's
something I'm going to put inside my
body because doing research before you
buy means making better more informed
choices especially when it comes to
stress or Sleep Products like CBD and
that's where next Evo Naturals my
favorite CBD brand knocks it out of the
park which isn't always the case a study
by an independent lab confirmed some
Brands contain up to 60 less CBD than
they claim on the label that's over half
less than they claim but with next Evo
you can trust you are getting the best
of the best plus they use smart sorb
technology proven that 30 times better
absorption in the first 30 minutes and
four times the overall absorption as
other products and that is really what I
tell people about next Evo when I
explain it to them people say they don't
know notice when they take CBD or they
don't know when it's going to kick in
next Evo isn't like that it usually for
me kicks in within 10 minutes and you
can dial in the dose just right because
you see it you feel it and you can get
it perfect for you you can tell they're
stress gummies which are CBD and whole
plant ashwagandha are Lifesavers when
I'm feeling overwhelmed and anxious if
I'm stressed and just can't get on with
my day can't face my inbox can't handle
company coming over family they are the
most secret weapon to round the edges
and get me back to feeling ready to face
my day if you've tried CBD before and
didn't get it or didn't feel it trust me
next Evo is different give it a try they
even have these unflavored packets that
I've been adding to my smoothies
sometimes a wonderful new way to get
super quick absorbing CBD into your
system but I also love their stress
gummies upgrade your CBD and show your
support of the show go to nextevo.com
weird to get 20 off your first order of
40 or more that's 20 off 40 bucks or
more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash weird alright
everybody let's get back to my pal Jay
Larson
I just think you're great thanks buddy
oh it's my jam bro I mean I had kids
names picked out in fifth grade wow you
know I mean in my notebook written down
with hearts around them chart boy girl
names well I I remember being the same
way I also remember fantasizing about
messing with my kids it's funny I don't
mess with my daughter yeah but I
remember thinking I was like I'm gonna
be the kind of dad that's gonna open the
door and go like hey your friend Miguel
called he said something about a red
rooster and it's gonna get you I don't
know let me close the door like that's
funny I thought as a kid I guess what I
was really craving was I wanted my
parents to be sillier yeah there was no
like and I I do mess with her and her
cousins a little bit yeah sometimes
they'll say something like you know
they'll complain like Uncle Pete I need
a Band-Aid and I'll be like or we can
bleed into the ground and get the
howling Moon yeah it's like weird [__]
because I don't want them to think that
that grown-ups are where the fun stops
yeah and I wonder where the absurdity
stops and you want to take their
imagination and blow it out as far as it
can possibly go that's right you know
what I said to them the other day
because we always have pushed
imagination my ex as well like I said
anything that you can see with your eye
that's not from nature was created
because of imagination someone had to
imagine whatever any like yeah any Dad
or Mom that's hardcore like you're gonna
play sports dude that person you still
like music you still like a color and
someone had to imagine it first so like
that's why like Einstein his biggest
thing was imagination the guy was a
physicist scientist right imagination I
pushed constantly so we joke around I do
try to my ex did make a very good point
to me one time about like how and
something that I really have tried to
curb since I got divorced is using
comedy as a way to avoid do you know
what I mean and I've I've so I've really
tried to like comedy shouldn't avoid
comedy should be steering the car into
the traffic yeah right yeah and the
Crash should be hilarious yeah instead
of like instead of avoiding feelings or
like situations or trying to make a joke
of everything like just sometimes be
around civilian and just be like oh I
can be a dad too I don't need to be the
guy who's a comedian around other dads
yes
um so I've like really worked at that
and my kids they know what sarcasm is
they are sarcastic they have sarcasm but
they also can just like have
conversations you know like there are
certain they don't have to do it because
the world is so but by the way sarcasm
great example
the world is so overwhelming I'll let
nothing in because I'll just be like
yeah that was a good idea yeah if I can
beat it you don't let anything in you're
never vulnerable to enjoy something like
look my brother and I were both kind of
like had some fear and anxiety stuff and
my brothers I say this with full
compassion one of the ways that he
guarded against fear and anxiety was by
hating everything yeah and I didn't know
until I was like 32 that you could just
like a movie that you could just be like
that was awesome I thought everything
was like it was stupid like that was how
to stay safe yeah yeah and people don't
really ask for follow-ups they don't
want you to build your case and why it
was stupid no I wasn't stupid just
didn't work
Steve Carell
yeah I just didn't like that's all you
had to do that's like a Jay Larson bet
if you get caught in a corner just say
people who are in the movie and then
yeah that's what that was Dedrick Bader
I used to love saying that about uh you
know the Godfather was great but Brando
come on like he's just horrible you know
uh as a bit but like even the sense of
humor like there I every morning I gotta
wake the kids up they're never really up
I gotta go in there so like I'll go in
my daughter's like tucked in and I just
go and I go hey
hey and one morning she just goes meow
meow first thing out of her mouth in the
morning was like I'm gonna pretend I'm a
cat you know and it's just like the
humor you know what I mean it's just
like so much closer meowing no no CEOs
how many movies do we need where
somebody like
wakes up a little bit lightens up a
little bit and does something in the
Board Room like we've come so far from
where we were as children it's funny
back to your point too about imagining
like Leela I got her like a pretty
sophisticated drawing program because I
couldn't find like a it doesn't matter
so she uses like the graphic designer
program so and like she's using it I'm
like before we draw let's let's picture
it in our minds let's picture in our
minds what we want to draw I was like
Wow someone like you're saying with your
kids someone has to point out that
quality that human beings have where you
see it
translucent and just floating amongst
the other stuff you see you can I don't
mean manifest reality you can manifest
visuals and sounds I think that's crazy
when you talk about physics saying that
reality is a shared hallucination right
that's not that weird when you consider
when I say Mario Lopez you see Mario
Lopez just for a second you saw him
totally in fact they did a study where
they would have people blind or that
they'd look in like a a light box and
and the light box was just white and
they would uh say think of a lemon and
of course you just briefly think a
translucent lemon then they start
showing them images Pink like real in
this reality images like before you can
even do it they'll go picture in Orange
and they do it like a half a millisecond
of an orange and nobody said are you
showing me images because it was exactly
the same so like showing pictures or
seeing pictures and also
let you know when you can hear someone
but you can't you couldn't say it or
recreate it it's like picture hear
Donald Trump hear Obama hear Michael
Douglas that's a good one I can't do
Michael Douglas but I I got him in my
head my brain can go like yeah there's
Gravelly or whatever so we can make
sounds and sights can I go a step
further yeah and it relates back to kids
I think there have been times with my ex
that we're taught our son or someone
will ask a question maybe right and we
don't have the answer and my daughter
has Like She's Got Confidence she will
give an answer of how to solve the
problem and then we'll sit there and
look at each other like I think that's
right and she has and we're but she's
never been exposed to whatever the thing
is and I believe that like you may not
even if before a kid knows what an
orange is their brain can already
conceptualize the idea of what this
thing is like so when you're saying your
brain would see things yeah and I think
what happens a lot with with adults and
kids again we've kind of touched on this
is we assume that they don't know the
fact that your daughter is already on a
graphic design program we would
automatically think oh they're not ready
for this but we don't know we don't know
that that's why like you need to give
kids space to make mistakes and to grow
and not assume that they can't do things
she's your daughter like your new
special with the bet about which I
hadn't heard you said you had done it
before about the guy calling you about
the budget and you just pretend to know
what he is that's what it is there's
like a child like yes I'm just gonna
talk imagine it's like I know and I'm
going to imagine that I know and and
kids have that in Spades what did you
just say you made me think of something
the program and the it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't
[__] matter just let it go um talking
about a man we are going to go to the
minerals yeah do it do you want to yeah
let's wait Jesus no you can say here's
the minerals oh guys
is the minerals
do you want to drink the magic mind
that's for you speaking of sponsors oh
that's Nirvana Water that's water that
prevents muscle loss deal with that and
that's magic mine that's
the world's first productivity drink
drink it
oh I love it I had one five minutes
before you got here it's my favorite
thing in the world I can't believe I
haven't honestly told you about it
before
I am invested yeah you mean emotionally
you mean financially he should have
given a little bit more Shake
isn't it lovely
uh well my friend James made it he's out
here in Cali I don't know where the
whole company is
yeah you're gonna enjoy you're gonna
like the way you feel I guarantee it has
that been taken by somebody
so what else Jay we're here in the SEC
we're here in the back half of the of
the you made it weird episode Jay Larson
number two I know I just want to say
this there was this one thing I would
mention about the bed getting in the bed
yeah so yesterday I was telling you that
we had this like great day right with
your kid yeah and I say you go hey and I
just set it up early in the day I just
want to let you know today we're taking
showers I'm cutting those Nails don't
even try and fight me on your nails and
three you're cleaning your rooms like I
will help I'll get in there so we
cleaned both of their rooms like me and
the kids not with my ex and like we went
through my son's whole room we threw
stuff out artwork you know we're like
I'm like bro do we need it throw it out
because you can throw it out I'm like
yeah it's good to clean and get and then
we went through all the clothes in the
drawer like does this still fit you
don't wear this let's you know and then
it's like you know they kids will just
wear their favorite shirt they don't
know what's down the bottom of the
drawer same please do this to my closet
keep going yeah so we go through the
whole thing we do and like then my son
is like ah I love my room and he just
like played in his room while I did his
sister's room with her and we did that
whole thing they both came out and
closed they never wear often today
anyway
when we went to bed oh no so later I
went like laid on my son's bed in his
room I was just chilling over there
while he was like drawing at his desk
you know
and I go I love your bed he goes I know
I have the coziest bed and there he goes
except for the one I have at Mom's and I
go is that the coziest yeah Dad it's the
coziest bed I'm like tell me about it
what do you love so much about that bed
can I please right there I know the
story continues yeah
that's a revelation it really is yeah
dude why do you have to say that man
your mom's bed is better like we're here
now can't we just be together yeah like
do you have to make it about me versus
mom like you can't see that that that
hurts my feelings like that's another
Choice yeah Rob Bell told me this he's a
wonderful parent as well he was like
when his kids are like um Jeremy at
school has a has a Corvette he'll go
what color
yeah instead of going like well we don't
have that kind of money and that doesn't
mean he's better than you or any of that
what color well that's amazing but this
is a revelation yeah everything it seems
like in the 80s was weaponized yeah and
turned into an attack yeah it's all in
attack it's like how comedians make
hecklers we make problems
my kids will say things that other kids
have and say they want them and I go
that's great to want it's really good
that's a great you know it's it's good
to want for things or strive for things
yeah there you go that's it yeah um so
get making bouquets [__] [__] earn it
but just that he can have that bed that
he loves more than the other one and so
this was like I always try to like I
come up with different stories as I'm
sure you do we all do for our kids we
all do stories yeah and uh so then I
they were getting kind of old on the
koala detective they were like you know
how many cases is he gonna solve you
know and uh so I stopped on call
detective so I was just laying next my
son reads like crazy so
they always want to hear him I was
getting the twist is always eucalyptus I
can't I don't know what to tell you guys
you know I can't no they wanted more I
was done I'm like I can't think of
another
thing I can't come up with another Caper
all right so I'm like lying next to my
son he's reading and I'm just lying
there and I just like watching him read
and then I just like furiously like tap
him on the shoulder he turns to me and I
go I go I go
you know when you
right here I sleep over here
and he just kind of looked at me and
then I just waited so he went back to
reading and then I was like I got how
much how much longer you're gonna read
because I want to go to bed too and so I
just pretended I was this little
character that sleeps next to him in his
bed right so the next night
I tuck in his sister I I'm in there with
her I come in he's reading he doesn't
look up from his book he's just like
laying there and he just reaches over
and puts his hand like back here and
starts like rubbing my head and he goes
do you think that weird little guy is
going to come back here tonight
which is basically like asking me are
you gonna do that guy again bro and um I
don't know how to ask this but
is that little weird guy coming back
that like my best dude
daughter's cousins were just visiting
and uh watching them as they get older
appreciate these types of things and
just seeing how much attention they're
paying and how much you're helping them
learn how to build the world and how to
have a relationship with the world it's
like you're right in that Prime pocket
yeah it's really exciting
so you did a comedy special sure and
it's called sounds like Bruce sounds
like bro sounds like Bruce
Bruce J uh shot in Austin Lance Banks
directed it who did Lance bangs very
nice yeah at the creek in the cave
there's a creek and cave in Austin yeah
is it that's where they moved yeah
that's how they moved there no and they
got this great venue and it's got a
beautiful stage and we you know came in
put a little touches on it and shot a
great special out there great and and it
comes out I self-produced it it I don't
know when this is gonna drop it comes
out April 19th so so you can watch it
now and and how do people watch it it's
on my YouTube YouTube backslash Jay
Larson comedy it's there
um I'm proud of it you know this is a
second cell produced special that I've
done yeah and uh it's it's a wild world
that you can do that you know what I
mean
um yeah you know it's funny I've been
like thinking a lot about comedy and
what comedy is I never I don't know
about you but like I never looked at
comedy as a thing that I even wanted to
make money on you know what I mean I was
just like oh yeah I think this is just
something like even when like and I
don't know if that's that like inner kid
being like whatever you know I'm not
getting a real job but like it felt
really good this one knowing that I'm
just like putting it out you know like I
put out there like Ari shaffir put out
there like if you want a venmo or PayPal
money because you appreciate what that
I'm putting this out for free please do
yeah and I did that did he put ads on it
too yeah I'll have ads on it I already
didn't but I am listen okay I'm okay
so I got miles to feed
um oh so his just ends with a venmo he
just has it in the in the bio in the
description like hey if you want you can
put you know if if you appreciate this
and this is something you can do throw
some money at it you know which I think
model yeah I will say there's a psychic
cost that's one of the things that I
find most interesting is you know we
monetize this podcast we're not shy
about that we have ads at the beginning
I always tell people it helps support
the show if you do it and there and yet
there is a cost like sometimes I just
feel it it's not every like the magic
mind I love that I just told you about
that for free and they're a sponsor so
that that's beautiful and natural it's
as clean as it can be and still
sometimes you're like wouldn't it be
nice if we were just handing everything
over just for its own sake yeah you know
what I mean and Rob Bell he's come up
again I was telling him how I do ads on
the podcast I was like to make it feel
clean I do add like this is my Apollo I
love it their sponsor these are perfect
jeans I love it these are all sponsors
of the podcast I love all of these
things for real
still there's a little bit of a a cost
and I think Rob knows that because I'm
like dude you love these types of
sneakers just reach out to that company
get a promo code put on the ad now
you're you're you're paying your
mortgage or whatever it might be and he
won't do it he doesn't do it and I think
those people people like what you're
saying they know it's like I'm saying
and I'm not gonna do this because I I
need a job you know what I mean yeah and
I can hear other people being like Oh
there's there's a cost dude I'm I'm
doing this job that I don't even like
that's a real cost shut the [__] up I
get that but there's something about
returning to a pure State and releasing
this thing as easily as it can be
consumed for sure and you know what else
I'll say on the other side the viewers
they want to they they were like how can
we help yeah I know we don't want to
just watch that's why when we do the ads
we go if you want to support the show
just buy one of these products like
think of it as a donation to the show
and you get the product for free like
that that helps it's crazy
until you become fans of things on your
own you're like yeah like there was this
one comment you're absolutely right
there was this comic who uh she got in
this terrible car accident and she like
just you know was losing it had nothing
and put a GoFundMe and was like I'm sure
that was really hard for her to do I
don't even know her and I'm like oh I
want to help yeah I want to send some
money yeah don't forget that people do
you're you could say
in let's take advertising podcast out of
it but like like in certain situations
you might be robbing people of the
pleasure of giving to you and helping of
helping you you know what I mean I've
had friends that are in tight spots and
I'm like why didn't you you know what I
mean like it would have been a a Mitzvah
as they said I've known people that have
committed suicide because of debt yeah
do you know what I mean and there's got
to be a different solution you know I
mean there's got to be a different way
out yeah I'm not saying you know when
you hear that's why you know what this
is another thing Pete tell me what you
think about this about like two months
ago I put in my Instagram stories
today would be a good day to check on a
friend yeah do you know how many
messages I got from people like hey dude
are you okay is everything all right and
I wrote back yeah everything's fine
I'm so tired especially in our industry
in stand up we lose like what three to
four Comics a year maybe you know what I
mean and it's felt like over the
pandemic through suicide and everyone's
like would a loss check on people it's
like how about you check on them when
they're not at the worst point of their
life right check on them when they they
feel they look like every and check on
your successful friends yeah because
they need someone to check on them too
they want it you know what I mean like
just give a ring hey what's up how you
been learn text let's quit smoking
before the lung cancer yeah yeah before
it's we're we're past a point of no
return or whatever it may be yeah
whatever it is that's a really good
point and what a weird telling thing
about the world that we live in that you
were like be nice to people and they're
like was someone mean to you yeah are
you okay and I'm like I'm not saying
check on me yeah I'm saying like go
check on other people yeah because I
just I know that like anytime someone
hits me up and they're like yeah I'm
just checking in I'm like oh that's
going so great yeah Ben Schwartz texted
me two days ago and he was just just
thinking of you sending love and I was
like it costs nothing nothing Joy costs
nothing yeah yeah to share yeah it's so
easy yeah we withhold it it's like the
diamond Market you know how they're
enough diamonds to go around and they it
they uh it's manufactured scarcity
interesting so they withhold I still
don't understand what's the value
between well that's what I'm saying is
diamonds are valuable because they're
scarce but they're actually not scarce
so they withhold them from the market to
make them scarce interesting so we do
that same thing with joy we're not
getting the love that we need so then
we're like more reluctant to give love
even though we all know talk about the
cliche it's one of those things that
when you give it that's actually how you
get it that's not only how you get it
that's how you have it yeah that's what
it is yeah it is flow it is outpouring
that's all it is holding on to it that's
something else I don't know what that is
that might be specialness or Pride or
something ugly but like we all know this
and yet we do the diamond Market to our
own Joy you go like well I'm gonna make
J I'd like to think I've been doing it
now to be honest like I'm telling you
how proud I am of you how amazing
it makes me feel great but it's also how
it's what love is yeah yeah but if I if
I withhold it again that's like the 80s
model it's like well I don't want Jay to
get lazy and like stop or something I
don't know what it is that is my I said
to my mom I go do you remember when we
were kids mom used to say
I'm gonna have three stickers on my back
windshield for the colleges that your
brothers and sisters went to and I'm
gonna have a flag on the antenna for the
community college that you went to she
said that she would say that to me and I
go do you know how hurtful that was she
goes well I just thought it would
motivate you that's what she used to say
you know what I mean but that's what but
what you just said by the way is like
exactly what I'm talking about with
comedy is like I always thought like you
just gave this thing away because at the
end of the day being funny whether you
think so or not it's like a gift it's a
right it's a talent it's something you
were given to be funny and people
when you go to a comedy club man like I
took someone to Comedy I'm on a date
with this woman and I took her to Comedy
she came to me I came with me I did a
show I mean she got to sit in the back
she did the comic web version but we
watched a couple of extra Comedians and
like we're driving home she's like wow
she's like I feel like amazing and I go
you're gonna feel like this for like two
days because you're laughing out loud
like spilling it out things that you
didn't think about things maybe you
didn't things you wouldn't have laughed
at you have realizations like oh I think
that's funny I didn't know I thought
that was funny well that's great what a
great articulation of of what comedy can
give you yeah especially when comedians
dial into
real things or what's real for them or
specific for them and it's not some
generic joke it's these things those are
my favorite comedians and like that's
why comedy always felt like just this
thing that I had to give away it hasn't
been since I've also
garnered self-worth and to take care of
my inner child and I'm single you know
what I mean before like we had we both
had incomes money was like oh pick and
choose when you want money you know what
I mean now it's like nah man you know
what I mean right anyway a lot of those
click that venmo link yeah hit it hit
that J Lawson
Jay arson been like here's the questions
you didn't get to answer last time you
were on the show oh yeah uh
uh have you ever unless you did I don't
know help me remember I can't remember
that far back seven years ago well have
you ever seen a ghost
no you seem like a guy that always
wanted to yeah but on my special I mean
you may not have seen it but I did
there's some crowd work in the special
yeah and I ask about ghosts yeah and
there's a guy who said yes and he goes
well and we go we go what happened and
he he literally goes well you know he
got possessed my friend got possessed
and we're like what this is a different
story from seeing a ghost and talks
gives this whole story but I was
throwing up possessed when they went in
this like abandoned house what yeah
possessed for like two months tried to
kill one of their friends with a knife
yeah Full Tilt I've always wanted to see
a ghost
not that kind what a great
pile of [__] to step in for your special
yeah I watched the first 20 in the last
10. so that because I didn't have time
to do the whole so I must have missed
that I appreciate you even asking and
like just diving in a little bit diving
um no ghost UFO
here's the third version you got one
I've never seen the UFO but do you
remember this is where kids are the
greatest
um we're driving in Santa Monica this is
like five years ago and all of a sudden
my daughter goes what's that and we look
up and it was like Elon Musk was testing
some rocket ship but remember that thing
boys musk do you remember that thing
look and I literally started recording
and I just said I'm like they're here
they're here like I was like oh this is
it this is it this is the day they are
the Double Rainbow Guy for UFOs like
when it happens I want it to be your
video that goes viral because they're
here guys they're here get out the
hummus plate cause they're here they're
gonna love him as he they're gonna love
him as he yeah apparently they put out
that ring of satellites around the earth
and whenever that happens there's just
thousands of UFO uh sightings because
he's it's Elon playing uh super villain
crazy isn't it crazy yeah see and it
[__] up uh telescope star gazing people
oh yeah because I don't because you
can't do like time lapse uh images
what's your whole vibe on UFOs I mean
it's not even a niche interest anymore
it's just like a confirmed thing yeah
right I mean I I don't even mean right I
mean like have you also seen this
happening but I like to hear people's
stories because they tend to be
Transcendent like body stopping moment
freezing moments yeah I bet what about
this I bet maybe you have one for this
something
unexplainable meaning the one I like to
use is I I was dating a girl I used to
call her Boogie I called a psychic by
the way I like to say this we never
wrote Boogie on each other's Facebook
pages there was no and I wasn't a public
person yet so there was no interest in
me got a phone number in a writer's room
I was in called the psychic I said I
want to talk about my relationship and
she said who's Boog I called her Boog
instead of Boogie Boog she goes who's
Boog who's bug that's that's an
unexplainable thing to me do you have
anything in that does that make you
think of anything something where you're
like the only thing you remember too
because you coined remember the golden
cashew I told you about the golden
cashew I remember I think about the
golden cashew all the time yeah
um so that was like an inexplainable
well for those that don't know that was
the last time you did the podcast yes
yeah you were stoned
right I was stoned and I left your body
and were and traveled down a black
Wormhole to an infinite black space yeah
and I was pre I was in it and there was
just a floating golden cashew yeah and I
started crying at an unbelievable depth
yeah you know yeah and then like I
opened my eyes and I would and like gasp
for air and I was like what was that and
then closed my eyes and I went right
back into the room or the space like was
just in it and it was just right there
in front of me and then was crying so
hard that it was just like this crazy
high-pitched sound coming out of my my
body by the way okay so I've had other
experiences since the last time you told
me this incredible story and there's
something called the DMT uh Yelp uh and
not an ndmt the 5meo DMT which is the
Frog Venom so when I did that one of the
people that did it did the the guy that
administered the medicine said that
there's a specific type of scream or not
scream scream sounds like Terror but
like a yacht yeah a Yelp
and one of my friends did it and was
like yeah it was like Dad and he was
like that's it
every time yeah
but you might have done like it's like
when these things when these
overcoming hallucinations happen there's
sometimes a sound version Terence
McKenna's even had these huge
unbelievable hallucinations but merging
over reality sort of like an augmented
reality hallucination and the the
vibrational noises that he made would
change he realized that everything's
vibration and he could go like oh and
like it would start to move like sounds
so like I'm not surprised that your
experience had a um Sonic uh variant
yeah so cool well I will say this back
to just on the third one that you said
like things that like unexplainable
I have taken on a complete acceptance
that every single thing that's happening
in my life is exactly what is supposed
to happen when it's happening right so
I'll find myself in like random
situations or someone or connecting or
seeing someone that just brought
something up and said something and
they'll always be like oh my God and I'm
like what and they're like they'll say
I'm like yeah this is exactly where
we're supposed to be I and I never yep I
never look at it anymore as like
coincidence or or like being random or
or like strange and just like yeah of
course like for me that's psychic
that psychic was put that number got put
in the room for you to call and to know
about bug
infinite time ago I agree you know yeah
I was just reading about this uh I do A
Course in Miracles in the lesson that I
was just reading was like
it was basically it uses religious
language it was like God knows every
step you'd ever take before time began
yeah so that's what you just said yeah
also this is a fun one that is what I'm
saying is I had a weird with you yes I
had a weird philosophy I don't know how
it happened with WP what is that weird
philosopher
um and it was that I I don't know how it
came into my head that all of our souls
I've got living souls are all connected
in one space energy wise and we spin
around each other and then when we're
born assault Refuge sultrifuge
um one gets ripped away from it and gets
put into a human and then you go and
live and have experiences then you bring
that back to the that's why I think
we're all connected but I had this
Vision that like we would write out what
exactly our life would be what we wanted
to be and then the whole purpose of life
was to just live to try and find that
true self like to find exactly what it
was and the only way to find it is to
let go completely and just allow life I
was driving with the kids two years ago
and my son goes Dad what's gonna happen
in my life and I go what do you mean he
goes like like what's what what is my
life going to be and I go buddy you need
to worry about only these things
be honest have fun work hard and there
was there was another one I said and I
go get the [__] out of my face
why do I feel like I said this I've told
you this before I don't think so oh wait
we do we golden cash
anyway and I was like if you do all
those things your life will just open up
in front of you and you just have to
keep moving forward yeah you just need
to do those things every day I love that
there there's again so going back to the
course and miracles of the lesson I was
just doing what is the course of mirror
it doesn't matter okay it's a it's a
text that a woman in the 70s channeled
okay it's very good I love it but it's
not for everybody but I love it anyway
one of the things I was talking about
being defenseless it's like we have all
these defenses against reality but when
we're defenseless that's when the truth
can like kind of descend effortlessly
into our mind and it's like if you're
defended if you're constantly trying to
organize the present as you want it to
be predict the future interpret the past
nothing new can happen it's just a good
Mantra if you sit down to meditate and
just go like I am defenseless completely
open completely spacious just like no no
guards at my door just like
let it all go so I'm doing that lesson
um the name of the lesson it's 135 and
it's if I attack if I defend I am
attacked and uh it doesn't matter but
the end analogy was today is your Easter
that's what this text is saying I was
like I did it on Easter it was Easter
how [__] nuts is that perfect there's
it's not like every lesson corresponds
to a holiday right and I take days off I
double a lesson I'll do the same lesson
three days in a row so the one day that
I happened to do 135 ago that today is
your Easter and I was like I'm like you
I go like of course yeah of course it's
just happening when [__] it makes me
enjoy moments so much more me too
instead of being like Oh my God I just
go
and I just feel like I'm seen this is
happening May Martin
you want a crack in there
dad do you think that guy is coming back
oh my God that was a good one
wow I didn't know I wanted this see you
know how I do it
sideways side side crack it apologies to
everybody that that grossed out
um May Martin was sitting right here we
were talking about the the myth of iron
John and the myth of iron John is about
a ball that represents your childhood
which makes sense because your mom's
womb was like a ball shape but your
innocence in mythology is often uh shown
as a ball anyway the ball rolls into a
forbidden place in the story of iron
John it rolls into the cage of the
monster known as iron John and you can't
just get it back from him he usually
gives you some tasks that you have to do
that involve cleaving leaving your
parents whatever and joining with him
and then he gives you your ball back so
the wild man the Obi-Wan the Morpheus
he's dangerous he's scary but he'll
actually he's the way to get your ball
back you have to free him and he'll give
you your ball back so we had a long
conversation about this that day that
day not the next day that day I go home
Leela wants to watch a cartoon she picks
she picks a new Disney show some [__]
Disney plus thing about fairy tales I
click on the episode she happened to be
watching was like half watch we start
watching it two kids playing with a ball
the ball goes over the the the fence of
a witch's yard and they have to climb
over the fence to get the ball they're
caught by the witch they have to make
friends with the witch and leave with
the ball and I was like it was that day
I was like this is just what's happening
yeah when you start getting into that
flow and you start getting honest this
is my ex I miss Mom too you start living
clean defenseless yeah totally something
new can happen something new and the way
that this world works is you get all
these little and you're not trying to
self-will everything you know thinking I
know what's best surrender it's all
surrendering all of it yeah totally I
wasn't expecting it but then you're also
not even surprised Valentine when we
first started dating I feel like
synchronicities were like a one so once
every two weeks would have a good
synchronicity now it's every it's every
day there's something every day that we
go like if we really stopped and thought
about that Easter on Easter yeah [__]
nuts yeah okay so great I love it I love
that you're living that way
uh have you ever almost died no I wish I
can't wait to die I think it's gonna be
rad I'm actually do you ever wrap your
head around like thinking about the
moment like having to let go and where
you'll be or like constantly I do it I I
it gets gets me to this point where I'm
like oh [__] like I start to feel like
you know what people will approach you
about saying like I think it's crazy
what you do you know what I mean I'd
rather die than do stand up yeah and
we're just like yeah no I I can't wait
at times to do stand up but sometimes
I'll just like allow myself to go free
into the thought of just not existing
and what would happen if everything went
quiet or what would happen and it it
changed I'm like whoa this is intense
but uh no I've never been around
I've never been super close to that
finish that thought do you mean there
are times when you can get into a state
where you're actually kind of looking
forward to that Liberation no I I start
thinking that I'm I've always said oh it
gets overwhelming I am 100 cool with hey
when it's my time it's my time I would
never I would it would suck for my kids
if I died like today and I'm you know
though nine and seven that would be
horrible for them but I'm okay whatever
my Pat because I'm just like I said I've
just turned everything over to like
whatever my path is going to be that's
my path is going to be and I say that
but when I dive into allowing myself to
go to a place where everything shuts off
it like it's like whoa that's intense
I've never been close to death I've
joked about it a lot because my humor
can sometimes be really dark it's like
dark on a level that you would never
think it's dark it's just I presented
very bright but it's like our teeth like
the Chris Thayer thing
um but uh no I've never I've always
wanted to pulled out by a Riptide as a
kid no one you never walked into traffic
someone yanked you back no no no I've
always been I think and I'm this is not
like a brag but I think I've always been
pretty aware of what's going around I've
never been in a close situation or
anything like that yeah I love it but
I've been close with I mean I sat there
with my nana like moments before she
died you know what I mean which was
pretty rad I was able was there when she
died I after I asked everyone to leave
the room and then I just said to her
like everything I thought about her and
what she meant to me and then she left
the room and then everyone came back in
and she died very shortly thereafter you
know wow yeah so you're with her yeah
and was it rough or was it peaceful oh
it was beautiful it was like awesome and
then when my my great aunt her sister
was dying I asked my brother he called
me from the room he's like it's not
going to be far and I go I go can you
put the phone right here and just let me
tell her some things and he's like yeah
and then there was
the comedian me this is I mean you too
he just he he pulled the phone back and
he's like oh you're still going I'm like
yeah he's like all right hold on like
the idea that he's just like oh hold on
you're still going like how you have to
eyeball how long you think that's gonna
be yeah probably three minutes yeah
I that's one of my earliest bits I never
did on stage it was pre actually doing
stand up just writing stand up when I
was like 12. I was like I think oh my
God 20 maybe not 12. I made that up
probably 16 17. I'm terrible with time
but uh I was like I used to think it was
funny when you'd be on the phone with
somebody like I'm on the phone with you
and this is what you hear I go like oh
sorry jay hold on one second yeah yeah
I'll just be off in like two minutes and
you're like I thought we were having
this great chat and this guy's giving us
two minutes I know yeah he ranks us two
minutes guys give me the light gave me
the light what's going on here that's
very I mean it it works um any new
thoughts about God
yeah I touched on some of them I I'm
definitely I don't know like I I think
God gets a bad rap because it's always
just tied to religion and some people
just like I don't want to be in part of
any organized religion because there's
so much yeah [__] that goes into it
but um what do you mean just kidding I'm
totally
in belief that there is a and like
there's a golden cashew yeah there's a
golden cashew but I also think that like
it's almost like each of us has an
individual God like that's connected to
us you know I don't know if it's
you know I don't necessarily think mine
might be yours or Katie's or anyone else
outside of this room you know what I
mean I think that we all just have one
Superior being that's looking over us
and whether that's
true or not or real or I don't know but
it's the thing that makes me appreciate
my life and be have gratitude and like
laugh out loud about my kids be in
horrible situations and still see the
Beauty and the light in all of it you
know what I mean so um I think I've
always felt that way and I think again
this is back to like parenting when we
were kids I think Soma and kids having
imagination in their own thoughts we
beat out of people God imagination
belief I agree dreams uh by just doing
things by saying it'd be nice of you if
you did that because kids at that age
not only are their brains so open to
believing anything that we teach them
you know I mean that's when you can like
groom a kid kids that are negative have
negative it's because it was pounded
into them when they were kids and for me
there was so much of me as a child that
just got [__] beaten out of them
mentally it's your ball yeah
yeah exactly and put that now
what's that I interrupted you said it
and I and I think that like you know
um for me personally I just lived so
much in like nope I'm gonna go control
this and I'm gonna like get control of
like you know whatever it is
my my life my just getting out of
Massachusetts to come to Los Angeles
that was the only goal was to just get
away from everything that defined me as
a human yeah you know what I mean yeah
let me just go be me somewhere away from
everyone that knows me was kind of like
the idea and then comedy kind of like
took hold and it didn't take until I
like to got divorced and like was able
to strip myself down to nothing to be
like what is so funny right now you
piece of [__] no I love it I love it you
know I love what you're I what if it's a
pun or an acronym I don't want to hear
it anything else please it's not it's
neither you know what's funny is I got
to watch anyone watching at home re go
back and watch Pete's you saw a little
smile come over his face he's like oh
he's being sweet like he's having a
sweet thought and then it wasn't it was
just the precursor because
I'm not saying it is bad but I can't
wait to hear what it is because
comedians are we can't help it a joke
Creeps in and it's whether we're like
yeah keep going with that joke hold take
hold and my friend Warren Brimmer wrote
this sketch we never shot it but it's so
this is what I couldn't stop imagining
it's a line of like Braveheart soldiers
like on a hill like about to storm
yeah another old that it's hold yeah but
instead of like a castle it's one modern
tank and the modern tank is just aiming
up it's like
like you think like laser systems in the
Braveheart guys going hold and it gets
back to the tank
it's just him he just well I think he
blows up like a big patch of them yeah
and then the Braveheart guy is like oh
he just doesn't understand and that's
what made me laugh and I'm so sorry that
would be a hilarious cold open it's a
great sketch yeah and Brewer I love that
at Oren Brimmer there you go but yes I
heard everything he said I actually
loved it and this is just what I like to
do I like to see where where we line up
your your soul trafuge thing the one the
inherent Oneness of the of the of all
beings is very beautiful and and seeming
to separate to have these experiences
and then the point of life being to
regroup that's very in line with me and
the idea that of having a personal
Depeche Mode your own personal Jesus
thing is also very in line with my
thinking and a lot of traditions that
I've studied which is the god Guru and
sell for one meaning like the the the
separation between you and God is an
illusion and it's your job here to wake
up from that illusion yeah it doesn't
mean you're this omnipresent all
powerful that's an ego trip it means
that the the spring of Life inside of
you is the only life there is there's
one life there's one love there's one
God and that's why we're here we're
having all these experiences and and
maybe those synchronicities are Winks
that we're doing the path I don't I
don't even know if that's true all I
know is I like what you said yeah I like
that and I know you're about to wrap up
hold hold
[Music]
I do like the idea of the guy who was
saying hold doesn't get blown away oh he
doesn't so mud and blood hits his face
but he doubles down yeah oh so like he
doesn't guys go Hey Arthur are you sure
we should keep holding this guy this
thing seems pretty cool for you you're
on the horse next to him he uh Arthur
real quick should we I feel like we
should stop
the hold sketch we gotta do I love it we
gotta do it I love it okay you were
saying something yeah but I'd rather end
on that I mean are we ending right now
yeah yeah I think that's better that was
fun that hold there's one more oh okay
in that case I used to do this joke
where I would say I go uh do you guys
honestly think anything's happening in
Cincinnati Ohio right now I go it
doesn't even exist I go until you get on
a plane and you're landing and then it
appears and then all this disappears
that's really funny it used to just be
like a thing you know well I mean don't
get me started we again on we made it
weird welcome back to don't get me
started this is the don't get me started
show but the idea there is an illusion
everything you've ever experienced
happens in the place called here
distance is an illusion just real quick
you close your eyes you feel your nose
like just feel your nose
and where do you feel that sensation you
feel it in the place called here you
just say if I feel it here
now feel the bottom of your feet where
do you feel that sensation
also here it's it's the visual
stimulation like when you open your eyes
and look well here's my nose now you're
imposing distance oh yeah but Cincinnati
and your feet and your nose everything
happens here sometimes it's manifests
when you get when I get really stoned I
feel like I'm on a treadmill and I'm
moving the Earth instead of I'm moving
I'm my feet are moving the Earth towards
me like I'm pulling the sidewalk towards
me with my feet that's a stoned version
of the very true realization that you've
only ever been one place called here and
you've only ever been in one moment
called now
deal with that golden cashew man oh
real quick real quick bro by the way if
you like that Rupert Spira he he's who
helped me articulate that feeling that I
was having but he's great s-p-i-r-a on
YouTube
um last question can you shut the [__]
up and get out of my [__] face yeah
okay
um last question um can you tell me the
time are you hurt no no not at all bro
you meant
um I was just making sure you knew I was
joking
um
can you think of the time in your life
when you laughed harder than you've ever
laughed oh bro you know what's so funny
is I haven't laughed crazy hard in years
and I assimilate I don't know if that's
the proper use of the word not just like
the pain I went through in the last
three years but like before that
you know as a comedian like everyone
else is dying laughing and we're in the
back of the room and we're just like oh
yeah I get why that works you know like
you're breaking down the joke yeah like
it's been very recent that I've been
like hey just watch you know like just
just like participate yeah whatever it's
like you know try not to be the funny
dad all the time just be a dad around
dads or be a person around people not
having to be this comedian that's you
know
and uh you know people might I feel like
I've gotten comedy shamed a lot in my
comedy life you know what I mean
sometimes my comedy feels alt or
sometimes it feels mainstream whatever
um I never forget I did a I did a Comedy
Festival and I was on like this panel
show and everyone was like who's the
greatest it was a very all teeth Vibe
who's the greatest like comedic male
actor and I was just like
Vince Vaughn like and people were like I
got booed other people were like what
and I'm like he's unbelievable you know
um wow thanks baby
you know what I what I no no no you know
what I like about that it was honest it
was honest you're doing you yeah
but like the only time I ever when
people the only thing
I'll never forget seeing something about
Mary in a movie theater
and I watched a human being roll out of
their chair into the aisle and I never I
never forgot like laughing so much with
a group of people you know what I mean
yeah
um I can think of moments there were
just so many moments when I was a kid
that we were laughing hysterically but I
usually was the one starting these
things or like being a part of them so I
never really think of moments where I
just laugh
uncontrollably anymore you know I mean I
I yearn for it I just went to New York
and did podcasts and I was like oh wow
I'm I'm laughing a lot you know what I
mean I'm finding Joy not through
something I'm not I'm not trying to make
people laugh and I was also able which
is something you've always been good at
to laugh at my to say something it was
funny and also laugh at it yeah you know
what I mean yeah whereas I used to think
like that was my Boston comedy I make
the joke you laugh you know what I mean
right and then I started was able to
like make jokes on podcasts while I was
back there and I would make the joke and
I'd be like like
isn't that fun that was fun you know and
I was like oh you can celebrate your own
comedy in a way yeah it felt really good
why not it's your time too yeah you know
what I mean I know but I just never it
was it for some reason there was a thing
that was implemented when I was a kid I
remember that being shamed you're
selfish if you laugh it was selfish of
me to do anything nice for yourself it
was selfish you had to do it for someone
else yeah that was kind of like the way
we were raised too I agree and it was
again my therapist come up twice uh who
I haven't seen in many years but he's
gonna do the Pod I'm excited he was like
I always wanted a girlfriend so I could
go get a massage and it was like just go
get a massage yeah that was like an
epiphany oh wow so you can just you can
just order Sugarfish yeah you don't have
to wait till you're dating somebody uh
yeah I used to have a friend that I
lived with and I didn't know that you
could I remember one time he went and
got food came home and and bought a beer
to come home and have a beer and watch
it and I was like what is this you could
do this you could just like be do these
little things for yourself this man's
loving himself would you light a candle
yeah lighting a candle that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not modeled
very much for men women are taking baths
and having a glass of red wine or
whatever we don't have that I get
flowers for myself that's what I do I
get flowers for myself are you kidding
me of course best past the floor oh it's
not a holiday it's [__] right now
baby yeah [__] yeah that's all there
is it's not the greatest I'm the
greatest actor thank you very much I
wish my events Bond was better we both
do well Jay I love you man I love you
too thanks for having me I'm proud of
you thanks buddy really impressed thanks
for whatever that keeps saying it but
it's true I'll take it I just think
you're an impressive guy thanks pal love
you need you go watch uh sounds like
Bruce yep on YouTube and share it
comment and you know it yeah and venmo
it would you say keep it crispy it's
just how we end keep it crispy
goodbye
thanks buddy
[Music]
thank you